I see I'm busy you're babbling Abbi you
have had your fair share of scandals but
you always come back swinging nothing
can keep you down or stop you from
pursuing your passions and it's a
deniable really so we don't understand
why you're so hard on your students when
it comes to making noise on the internet
but we totally know where you're coming
from you just want the best for your
girls
luckily the executives at lifetime are
pretty good at covering up potential
scandals getting caught up in the
scandal when you're a child star isn't
an easy thing to cope with but
thankfully the girls the ALDC have
lifetime executives who go the extra
mile to cover up their tracks we're
about to reveal the top eight scandals
to ever hit the stars of Dance Moms
so don't go anywhere it's because I'm
afraid of hard work
Mackenzie Ziggler's vapes scandal when
Mackenzie was 13 years old a video of
her using a vape surfaced on the
Internet and things got heated fans
scolded Mackenzie for promoting a
product that contained highly addictive
nicotine content and the young star
fired back claiming that it was an
organic faith that helps soothe her
anxiety but that explanation didn't fly
with Abby Lee Miller who was in jail at
the time of the scandal she shaded
Mackenzie for her actions but Kenzie's
diehard fans fired back telling Abby
that she shouldn't talk because she had
her fair share of scandalous moments
Kyra's troubled past stepping into the
spotlight can go one of two ways your
embrace by fans or your destroyed by
critics reporters started digging into
curator arts past when she joined the
cast of Dance Moms in season 4 and
things quickly got ugly during one of
Kalani's rehearsals
jessalyn and ashley brought up a telling
article about Kira's troubled past and
she wanted nothing to do with the
conversation but the truth got out
either way just keeps coming with them
Ashley and as it turns out Kira was
indicted on four counts of felony theft
and one attempted theft in Arizona
Kira's stole a total of fifteen thousand
dollars but clearly that was the old
Kira the new Kira definitely learned her
lesson the truth comes out it wouldn't
be the first time that the moms at the
ALDC called Melissa a liar in season 4
episode 7 many of the moms were upset
with Abby for bringing Kira and Kalani
onboard but one incident really pushed
them over the
Mady and Cara were given a secret solo
and asks to perform but when Chloe asked
Maddie about it she lied to her face
[Music]
Christi and Kelly got mad and took
things way too far but luckily the
Ziegler's weren't fazed by the drama
pavani Hilliker sings her way into a
vaping scandal in the winter of 2018
Kalani Hilliker released a very risky
video that literally scarred her younger
followers for life
despite being 18 years old at the time
Kalani has a very young fan base which
is why she shouldn't promote excessively
mature content in this short video we
see Kalani vaping while singing along to
a very inappropriate song the dancer
received a lot of hate for her actions
but she didn't seem too shook up about
it
the Lucchese act scandal the Lucchese
acts didn't have an easy run on Dance
Moms
Abby was known for picking on Chloe to
get back at her mother Christi but one
day she went way too far
Dance Moms executives made sure that the
footage never made it to air and they
tweaked the footage and Abby's favor so
while the TV screen showed a be calling
Chloe washed up the dance teacher
actually told Christi to go fix Chloe's
eye which was a product of Chloe's
ongoing medical condition Brynn rum
follow follows the vaping trends
it looks like vaping runs in The Dance
Moms family because even the sweet and
innocent brand run follow fell victim to
the trends strand posted a picture of
her and a friend holding vapes in their
hands when she was just 14 years old her
fans totally lost it telling her that
she was only doing this sort of stuff to
be cool but Brynn soon posted an
Instagram story about the incident
stating that she was 14 years old and
allowed to make mistakes Maddie Ziegler
tells all Maddie Ziegler isn't one to
get caught up in a scandal but Jack in
2018 a video of her chatting with
ex-boyfriend Jack Kelly and the friends
started to circle the internet in the
video Maddie mentioned that she was 15
years old when she and Jack got together
and the team was immediately scolded for
oversharing Maddie has been under fire
for acting to boy-crazy from a very
young age but these comments went in one
of her ears and app the other Highlands
versus Miller in season four episode 7
of Dance Moms Kelly Hyland got into a
physical altercation with
Miller in front of the entire cast the
fight got ugly real quick an Abbi
immediately alerted the police the
unforeseen event led to Kelly Paige and
Brooke Hyland leaving Dance Moms for
good the fans just couldn't get over the
scandalous episode lawsuits are filed
and the Hyland's met Miller head-on and
the rest is pretty much history everyone
makes mistakes and while it's easy to
judge people by their actions and what
we hear on social media we're talking
about real-life people and not robot
girls should be allowed to wear bikinis
without receiving any hate being a
teenager is hard enough as it is and
teens blunder now and then but the stars
of Dance Moms aren't acting any
differently than other girls their age
so let's all give them a break who is
your favorite Dance Moms star tell us in
the comments section below give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to the things thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]